motion for sub-arbitration to determine
whether or not that's sad motion
accepted all in favor aye aye aye motion
passed sad i'd also like
even the arbitrator voted for the motion
that's fantastic amazing
i've reacted to it's always sunny in
philadelphia twice but the fans were
very specific they wanted one more
reaction and they were
very vocal about which particular
episode so i put on my weirdest suit and
let's react to it's always sunny in
philadelphia hero or hate crime
oh man look at this dog
did you just step in that on purpose
oh no i just you know i didn't really
see it you pointed it out to me i was
just gonna
yeah is that a lottery scratcher
[Music]
who voice pianos like an old-timey
cartoon
look out
holy [ __ ] what the hell was that what i
saved your life but you called me the f
word so what i'm a hero you use the slur
dude that's like a hate crime yeah
that's hateful speech man yeah he saved
his life really yeah
that word anymore so which is it
so danny devito has saved mac's life
by yelling out a homophobic slur at the
same time and i guess the gang is going
to figure out if he's a hero or if a
hate crime has been committed all right
i'm on board let's find out
excuse me hey can i help you okay look
usually we're a pretty reasonable crew
yeah right i mean we have our
differences but we settle them in house
sure process there's filibusters the
whole thing no this one okay are they a
reasonable crew i've never gotten that
impression before filibusters i believe
this one's a doozy yeah this one we
can't do in-house that's why i wanted to
bring in a third party someone to hear
us out and deliver a final verdict yeah
that's you that's right because a great
injustice has occurred okay they went to
arbitration i hate crime i saved your
life well you used a slur it was a slur
you'd be dead if i didn't okay okay i
think i'm getting it you want me to
figure out whether or not a hate crime
has been committed
what no no no way off no no no no
i mean that's good because there is
definitely no hate crime here we'll
probably talk about that more i'm
guessing later on no no it's not about
that at all yeah it's about this
a two-dollar scratcher lottery ticket
yeah
you've hired an arbitration attorney to
figure out which of you is entitled to a
two-dollar scratcher now you're getting
it he's yeah he's getting it
he's a smart guy
okay so uh this is great they went to
arbitration um arbitration is a thing
that you can do you don't have to go to
court if you have an issue that would
normally be adjudicated by the courts
you can by agreement with another party
agree to take it to a neutral third
party an arbitrator and have everything
arbitrated the arbitration basically
carries the force of law so the
advantages of arbitration are that you
can basically make up whatever rules
that you want it's usually much faster
but it can be more expensive because the
state isn't paying for the judge you
have to actually pay for the judge the
arbitrator's time so there's pros and
cons
each one of us feels that we're entitled
to that ticket we need you to tell us
who it belongs to yeah why don't you
scratch it and see if it's worthless and
then you wouldn't have to go through all
of this okay so he's not getting it
hold on is it okay yeah so look it
doesn't matter that the scratcher might
not be worth anything you can arbitrate
whatever you want you just have to pay
for the arbitrator's time it's
completely up to you so uh so far this
is actually much more realistic than the
prior examples on it's always sunny
because
basically anything goes in arbitration
this ticket represents hope okay
potential
yeah promise
the very foundation upon which this
group rests huh yes and that hope
belongs to me it belongs to me you son
of a [ __ ]
are you crazy
please stop
each of you will have an opportunity to
plead your case
the only rule i have is that you each
treat each other with respect and common
courtesy
do we all agree to those terms
[Music]
that's incredible so
in arbitration because everything is
done by mutual consent
the parties do have to agree to the
arbitrator so
if you're not happy with the the
arbitrator that you would normally get
then you can keep going until you find
an arbitrator that everyone agrees on so
it's absolutely hysterical that
the the one rule that he that everyone
treat each other with uh compassion and
respect that's that's a deal breaker for
the gang perfect a plus love it we would
like to thank you so much for taking our
case so last minute the other guy was
not our style well i'm very happy to do
so
i do have a few questions fire away yeah
yeah
now the ticket in question uh who
purchased it me thank you that was me
and that's why this whole thing is so
cut and dry hold on i purchased the
ticket and therefore the ticket belongs
to me
i actually bought the ticket a couple of
weeks ago
but i didn't realize it was gonna be so
goddamn blustery that afternoon
yeah so i actually think this is
probably pretty cut and dry dee
purchased the ticket
it came out of her purse for just a few
seconds really the only argument against
it is if she abandoned the ticket but
that's a pretty high standard to make it
it requires an overt act that clearly
shows the owner has relinquished control
and the owner has to actually intend to
get rid an abandoned said thing and then
basically any third party can come and
take the thing that has been abandoned
we're talking about losing a scratcher
ticket for just a couple of seconds when
the wind blows it away there's
absolutely nothing that she did that
shows an affirmative act to abandon the
scratcher ticket i think this one is
pretty cut and dry
at least with respect to the ownership
of the ticket
whether there's a hate crime or not i
guess that's a separate issue the ticket
flew out and landed on the ground
so you purchased a ticket two weeks ago
i did and why hadn't you scratched the
ticket yet oh well that's because nobody
ever wins those tickets right but as
long as you don't scratch it then you're
not a loser
you know in fact you're a winner
potentially oh god this is so sad
god that is god it's so sad dee that is
that's so sad of her to say jesus exact
same thing like 10 minutes ago talking
about how the ticket represented host
no that's totally different
totally different motion for
sub-arbitration to determine whether or
not that's sad motion accepted all in
favor aye aye motion passed sad i'd also
like
even the arbitrator voted for the motion
that's fantastic amazing while dee's
version is the truth
it's not the whole truth
why don't we talk about the contents of
dee's purse the scratcher ticket the
candy sour worms the pack of cigarettes
now what i want to know is
how can a woman who makes less than
minimum wage afford such impulse buys
so you're smoking now dee how can you
actually afford
to smoke
you see dee and i had a deal i give her
money for coffee every morning on the
way to work
she's instructed to give a very generous
tip to the cashier cassie
this is from my boss dennis
now this establishes both generosity and
authority
[Music]
okay so the argument is that
dennis is her boss
and because of the employment
relationship
it's outside of the scope of her
employment to have purchased the
scratcher ticket that is interesting
okay so that that might work so
that's a tough one though because is it
really within the scope of her
employment to tip
the woman that works behind the counter
there you can imagine that if your boss
gives you money for
i don't know petty cash for lunch and
then you you go out and buy alcohol that
seems like it's outside the scope of
your employment and theoretically your
employer could then
sue you for the balance that was
misappropriated by the employee that
one's interesting now wait a minute okay
so there's a really interesting wrinkle
here in that even if dennis is right
that's outside the scope of dee's
employment and uh that
she owes him damages as a result of that
the remedy here is probably not specific
performance specific performance is
where you have to turn over the actual
thing you see this in real estate a lot
where
a house or a piece of land is considered
unique so
if there's a breach of contract you have
to turn over the piece of land whereas
in almost all of american law the remedy
is usually damages in the form of money
so here
you could argue that even if dennis is
right he doesn't get possession of the
ticket he gets
compensation for the amount that dee
should have been spending on the tip
rather than the uh the lottery ticket so
i don't think he would be entitled to
the ticket or the funds from the ticket
if the ticket is worth something
that is that is a very complicated legal
issue to think about in uh just the
first 10 minutes of this show this is
fantastic
possibly a little dominance it's all a
very choreographed dance between two
soon-to-be lovers
cassie's underage oh no no wha wha what
are you talking about cassie is not
underage cassie is 21 years old
so the champagne i was purchasing i mean
the age of consent is generally 18. in
some states it's less than that so
underage
uh not in a legal sense but sort of in a
moral sense that like this guy who's you
know over 40 shouldn't be uh harping on
someone that just turned 21 or is about
to turn 21 that's kind of gross dee has
no rightful claim to that ticket and
i'll prove it
see yesterday after noticing the
contents of her purse i decided to
follow her this morning
cassie never gets her tip
does she d
no because i refuse to tip for coffee i
think it's done uh-huh
so if you were buying circus peanuts and
candy sour worms and cigarettes i think
we all know what that means about the
ticket in question don't we
i don't do you know no totally lost
that means she bought it with my money
so technically that ticket is mine okay
okay okay
yeah i i don't think so he might have a
claim for reimbursement i don't think he
has any rightful claim to the ticket
itself uh also you know it's a two
dollar scratcher who cares but i know
i'm sure they'll accuse me of not
getting it either
now let me sum up the facts thus far
miss reynolds bought the ticket with mr
reynolds money but mr mcdonald currently
possesses it correct but i deserve it
and here's why
okay so the law says nothing about who
deserves what it's about compensating
people for past wrongs
i don't
look charlie is not a legal expert even
in bird law so
okay well
filibuster
do you do you know what that word means
yeah what's that mean
i don't think this argument is gonna
work but let's let's hear him out here
there we were right we were just walking
down the street minding our own business
i just spotted the perfect pile of dog
[ __ ] and naturally i stepped in it look
doesn't matter anyway all right because
i deserve the ticket because it's a
shoe's a matcher charlie gets the
scratcher oh
but look if it smells like [ __ ] you must
have quit you know what if everyone's
gonna be smoking
all right as expected complete legal
insanity uh though i do like the
references johnny cochran um man charlie
is just the the legal clown that keeps
giving it's uh
the writers of the show must know what
they're doing to write charlie's so
insane from a legal perspective it's
just it's wonderful to watch look nobody
is debating whether or not the shoe
print is yours i mean
can they can they actually smoke indoors
i i can't imagine that that is legal in
philadelphia so i imagine that this is
probably a you know laws broken we all
know that it is because everybody saw
you kick me we're debating whether or
not you actually saved my life which you
did not because i was just about to do a
sweet backflip to say
had i not warned you thereby saving your
life that is my ticket
okay i don't get it even if frank did
save his life
why would he be entitled to the ticket
just
general morality that if you save
someone's life you're entitled to
something from them
that's uh i think that's gonna be dumber
than charlie's argument the point is
that i said look out
which were the words that saved mac's
life thereby i am entitled to at least
half that ticket that is complete
nonsense
whether the slur is used or not it
doesn't make any sense well why did you
use the slur instead of just yelling
your friend's name well there was a lot
going on i needed something that would
cut through
what i mean still i said this stuff
everybody knew to look at mac
okay it may have been effective but it
was an offensive slur
and a bigot should not be entitled to a
hero's payoff you're allowed to use any
language you want to save somebody's
life
i mean
okay this is completely off the rails
but i have news for the whole gang here
you're allowed to use whatever language
you want almost all of the time there
are only a few exceptions to the first
amendment none of which apply here and
we often talk about hate speech or hate
crimes but
there's no cause of action
that something in and of itself just a
word itself is hate speech and therefore
it must be punished now a lot of people
disagree with that they think that hate
speech or
slurs or particularly offensive language
should be illegal now where you fall in
that particular debate doesn't matter
because we have the first amendment and
as long as we have the first amendment
it's going to protect people being able
to say things like that so for the most
part
the definition of a hate crime is
something that is an actual crime but
it's enhanced because of the particular
racial or sexual motivation that is
associated with that particular crime
that is a crime apart from whatever
words are used so
this is not a situation where there is
any kind of hate crime because hate
crimes don't apply to just mere words
really any language yes let a man die
over a word come on it's just a word
just a word oh okay well frank tell me
something if you were going to save
somebody else's life you know from a
falling piano and you needed a word to
just to just cut right through what word
would you use
to call out to the arbiter
uh he means arbitrator
but
good luck with that one frank
uh
i suppose
okay let's um
let's just move on
well um
i think we've seen enough i've certainly
learned something
this this has nothing to do with being
gay this is just the work of a man who's
an extreme sexual deviant
gay or not can i have one of those yeah
whatever or whatever you guys are just
jealous because i've got a
million-dollar idea and i've got the
ticket okay he has the ticket uh i don't
think he has a legal claim to the ticket
i also don't think that's a
million-dollar idea
oh no and okay so theoretically what
does dee do if she has a claim to the
ticket and mac doesn't want to
relinquish it uh she would
sue him for conversion you actually
don't believe in evolution anymore i
don't know he created a reasonable doubt
he makes you sound like a stupid um
science
uh for effectively simple theft of the
thing and here
since mac hasn't paid anything for it
it's not like the the dennis situation
where d was supposed to take a certain
amount of money but used it for other
purposes uh d would then sumac for
conversion and the damages would be the
value of the ticket itself so d would be
entitled to whatever the ticket is worth
from mac
uh we'd need to scratch the ticket to
find out how much exactly but again she
can't sue for a specific performance of
the ticket itself i don't think
and i will make my decision
but let me make one thing clear
in order for this to be entirely just
i will make my decision based on
fairness
and compromise
she's you understand she's getting the
boot
okay
so good all right so what's the verdict
yeah what do you got so i've never run
into a situation where and i've
participated in many arbitrations where
the parties have mid-stream decided to
get rid of the arbitrator i can't
imagine that there's any reason why you
can't do that
but you can imagine that you're gonna
have to start over which would be
extremely expensive so you're not gonna
see it all that often by the way
arbitrators are really expensive they
often are former judges and um so if an
attorney
might be charging 500 an hour in a given
area which is probably
middle of the road for a big area like
la or new york an arbitrator might
charge two or three times that it's not
uncommon for an arbitrator to charge
1000 or fifteen hundred dollars an hour
because if they are a former judge then
you know they're in high demand now you
can hire a cheaper arbitrator these
specifically they said that this is an
arbitration attorney rather than a
former judge so they're probably not
going to charge that much but still
arbitrators are really really expensive
i think i'm all caught up all right so
what's the verdict yeah what do you got
i think it's actually pretty
straightforward
mr mcdonald is in possession of the
ticket so he has ownership no absolutely
not
it's an old wives tale possession is
nine tenths of the law not a thing
absolutely mac does not get possession
and ownership of this ticket no way
however he would not be in possession if
his life were not saved by mr reynolds
who set off the chain of events saving
it totally irrelevant to others i see it
as a 50 50 split what that scene kidding
me i'm a hero i'm the hero
nothing for the man who paid okay that's
completely wrong not based in law
whatsoever however
arbitrators can often make any decision
that they want to now their decision has
to be based in law so it's not so much
the outcome that can be challenged here
but the process by which this arbitrator
came to this decision so if she can't
back up this 50 50 split in law which i
don't think she can then you would
appeal this decision to the trial court
and eventually to the court of appeal um
which would be even more expensive
and insane in this particular situation
so i really like this episode but i this
arbitrator is really missing the ball on
this one nothing for the man who paid
for the ticket i bought it and this
bigot here is gonna get a hero's payout
he may be a bigot and he did use
disgusting speech but
it's not technically hate speech since
mr mcdonald does not claim to be gay
oh yeah no
something can be hate speech but that
has no legal repercussions um that
hate speech is is not something that's
really codified in law so
it doesn't really work here either way
but there are no legal repercussions to
come as a result of whether it is or is
not hate speech
oh does that mean if i claim to be gay i
get all of it well um
yeah yes you would be entitled to keep
all of it i claim to be gay
there's a history behind it
forever everybody knows it hey uh excuse
me would you please do the honors on my
ticket please oh you're a winner what
how much
ten thousand dollars
all right if uh you'll just take care of
this then uh we'll be all done what's
this that would be a bill
i know it's steep but you did go through
three arbiters and you've been here
17 hours
what's that what's it add up to their
friend 9 986
okay that is totally reasonable 17 hours
9 000 so uh a little over 500 an hour
yeah
that is that is honestly right in line
with what i can imagine uh an
arbitration attorney would actually cost
so that's that's perfectly realistic
holy cow you guys aren't vaping you guys
aren't cheating yeah the arbitration was
mack's idea
let's let him pay that's a great idea
that's fair
fairness yeah he's got the money for it
he's got the money now yeah yeah except
they all agreed to it and believe me you
would sign all kinds of contracts every
single one of those people would be
liable for the cost of the arbitrators
because you know they want to make sure
that they get paid all right so let's
give this episode of it's always sunny
grade for legal realism
[Music]
on the one hand arbitrators are
expensive
they can set whatever rules they want
and honestly this is not the most
unrealistic portrayal of an arbitration
proceeding on the other hand they're
arbitrating over nonsense their legal
arguments were completely
insane and the arbitrator had no bearing
in fact or law whatsoever so overall i'm
gonna give this episode if it's always
sunny a b-plus nice job now if you'd
like to listen to more legal stories
that are even more accurate than it's
always sunny you should listen to john
gresham's new legal thriller the judges
list with today's sponsor audible it's
the story of investigator lacey stoltz
as she follows the trail of a serial
killer and closes in on a shocking
suspect a sitting judge he is the most
cunning of all serial killers because he
knows forensics police procedure and
most importantly the law now honestly i
was gonna make a joke about john grisham
but frankly that sounds pretty awesome
i'm definitely gonna listen to that
because i use audible almost every day
it's by far the best source of audio
entertainment i listen to audiobooks
when i'm running cleaning up or when i'm
supposed to be listening to friends or
loved ones audible is the leading
provider of spoken word entertainment
all in one place if you tried to listen
to everything that they have it would
take three centuries and as an audible
member you'll get one credit every month
good for any title in the entire premium
collection which includes basically
every bestseller new release or memoir
and those titles are yours to keep
forever in your audible library you'll
also get access to their popular plus
catalog which is filled with thousands
and thousands of audiobooks original
entertainment guided fitness and
meditation sleep tracks and shows all
included with your membership no
credit's required and audible is running
a special holiday promo for legal eagles
so now is the absolute best time to join
new members will get 60 off for the
first three months that's only 5.95 a
month all you have to do is click on the
link that's on screen right now or in
the description or go to audible.com
legaleagle so right now for a limited
time save 60 on your first three months
of audible by clicking the link that's
on screen and while you're at it click
on this playlist over here with all of
my other real lawyer reacts videos so
click on this playlist or i'll see you
in court